concernant le comité de sélection
oui s'agissait de trois membres du
cabinet et de trois membres du cpdr
autant je m'en souvienne la raison de ce
format était lié aussi
à l'idée de travailler en sur une
matière comme très sensible de rester
entre ceux qui avaient vocation à
connaître le sujet
et je vais répondre très directement à
votre question monsieur le Président et
avec l'autorité politique chargée de
valider mais de contribuer aussi à des
échanges par définition avant de décider
formellement de déloréat
je tiens à préciser avec toute
l'humilité qui doit nous caractériser
que il y avait néanmoins au sein du cpdr
des compétences en matière de
communication digitale la chargée de
mission qui avait un rôle de chef de
projet pendant plusieurs mois
connaissait très bien ces questions
aussi de contrediscours sociétal en
ligne
avait travaillé sur ces projets là
depuis ce type de projet depuis quelques
années
la responsable
de l'époque de du pôle métier concerné
était issu du privé avait été l'un des
cadres d'une société reconnue sur la
toile donc une connaissance des codes du
web clairement et
votre serviteur a été directeur du
Service d'information du gouvernement
pendant trois ans
avec une dimension digitale extrêmement
forte d'ailleurs qu'on avait fait
émerger qu'on avait développé
considérablement à l'époque où j'étais à
la tête de sa structure et j'ai été
aussi enseignant en sciences po sur des
questions de communication où je vais
donc moi-même travailler étudier fait
associer des experts sur ces sujets là
également à mes cours et à mes
réflexions pour vous dire que en tout
cas on n'est pas totalement déconnecté
de ces questions là au CP